Être médecin c'est quand même un métier super difficile.
Bon moi je ne suis pas médecin, je suis infirmier
mais médecin vous imaginez...
Faut faire des études super longues, faut mettre ses mains à l'intérieur des gens
et puis surtout faut jamais faire d'erreurs !
Ouais parce qu'un médecin qui fait une erreur, ok, il la paye cash
mais c'est surtout les autres qui prennent cher...
Parmi les erreurs médicales qui ont marqué les esprits, il y a celle du docteur Rolando Sanchez
C'est un chirurgien qui a été jugé en 1995 en Floride pour avoir amputé le mauvais pied à un de ses patients de 52 ans.
Pour se défendre l'homme a expliqué que le personnel du bloc opératoire avait préparé le mauvais côté
et que le membre en question était de toute façon en tellement mauvais état qu'il aurait sûrement fallu l'amputer un jour ou l'autre
C'est d'ailleurs sans doute la raison pour laquelle il n'a pas pris le temps de vérifier lui-même sur le dossier du patient qu'il opérait bien le côté prévu
Bien sûr...
Le chirurgien a été suspendu 6 mois, le patient lui, bah il a été se faire amputer l'autre pied dans un autre hôpital
et il est décédé 6 ans plus tard.
En 2010 c'est une patiente de 90 ans qui a subi à peu près le même sort en Autriche.
Cette fois c'est sa jambe entière qui lui a été retirée, du pied jusqu'à la hanche, par erreur.
Ils ont retiré la mauvaise, enfin la bonne du coup
"Loupé, c'est bête !"
On est d'accord, confondre sa gauche et sa droite quand on est chirurgien c'est embêtant...
Alors imaginez quand c'est 3 chirurgiens d'un même hôpital !
C'est arrivé en 2007 à Rhode Island où trois neurochirurgiens différents ont ouvert le crâne de leur patient respectif, du mauvais côté
et tout ça, la même année. Bon cette fois ils se sont rendus compte de leur erreur avant de commettre l'irréparable,
ils ont refermé et ils ont opéré le bon côté.
Mais comme on l'a vu, ça ne se termine pas toujours aussi bien,
la même année à Los Angeles, un chirurgien a retiré à un homme de 47 ans le testicule droit au lieu du gauche
"Sorry"
En Caroline du Nord en 2002, une patiente de 46 ans a subit une ablation des deux seins
parce qu'on lui avait découvert une forme très agressive de cancer.
Il s'est avéré après l'opération que sa poitrine était en fait saine et que ses analyses avaient été mélangées au labo avec celles d'une autre patiente.
Et en 2011 à la Réunion un patient s'est vu retirer un rein en parfaite santé, ne lui laissant que celui qui était malade
"C'est offert par la maison"
Dans ces cas certes dramatiques, les patients ont survécu.
Jessica Santillan elle, elle a pas eu cette chance.
En 2003 cette jeune mexicaine de 17 ans a enfin reçu la greffe pour laquelle elle était venu vivre aux Etats-Unis 3 ans plus tôt,
un cœur et un poumon qui étaient en réalité incompatibles, parce qu'ils provenaient d'un donneur qui n'était pas du même groupe sanguin qu'elle.
Son organisme les a massivement rejetés, créant des dommages irréversibles et malgré une nouvelle greffe avec des organes du bon groupe sanguin cette fois,
l'adolescente est décédée.
Le cas de cette jeune fille est très rare, mais il y a d'autres erreurs qui sont très courantes.
Comme le matériel chirurgical oublié dans un patient avant que le celui-ci ne soit "refermé".
"C'est une véritable boucherie à l'intérieur"
Grand classique: les compresses oubliées dans le ventre.
Le personnel du bloc opératoire est censé compter les compresses utilisées,
puis compter le nombre qui sont jetées à la fin de l'opération, mais parfois le compte n'est pas bon.
*notes de piano*
C'est ce qui est arrivé en 2011 à un patient de 72 ans, opéré dans les Hauts-de-Seine pour ce qu'il pensait être une tumeur de plus de 16 cm.
La tumeur s'est avérée être en réalité une compresse, laissée là 11 ans plus tôt par un chirurgien.
Parfois il s'agit même d'instruments.
La même année à Lyon une patiente a du être réopérée pour lui retirer une pince oubliée dans son abdomen 7 mois plus tôt
et qui commençait à ressortir toute seule par son nombril.
Parmi les nombreux autres cas on peut aussi citer celui de cette patiente de 34 ans, qui a vécu 7 mois avec une lame de bistouri dans le ventre, en Île de France.
Mais la palme revient à un gynécologue jordanien en 2015 qui après avoir pratiqué une césarienne sur une de ses patientes
ne retrouvait plus son téléphone portable.
et pour cause...
*sonnerie de téléphone*
Quand on regarde d'un peu plus près les causes de ce genre d'accident on retrouve parfois une accumulation d'erreurs individuelles
mais le plus souvent un non respect des procédures à un moment ou à un autre.
Pour gagner du temps par exemple.
C'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles la course à la rentabilité dans le domaine de la santé, c'est pas une bonne idée
*bruit de buzzer*
"Mauvaise idée"
On n'a pas de statistiques fiables sur les accidents médicaux en France
Mais les associations de défense des victimes avancent le chiffre de 450 000 cas, entraînant 30 à 40 000 morts chaque année
Attention, là on parle d'accidents au sens large, c'est à dire pas uniquement des erreurs individuelles
mais aussi des effets secondaires de médicaments, des infections nosocomiales etc...
L'office nationale d'indemnisation des accidents médicaux (ONIAM), a été créée en 2002 pour gérer ce genre de cas.
Je vous mets le lien dans la description, je vous le souhaite pas, mais on sait jamais, ça peut servir.
Voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui, continuez de vous faire soigner quand même, la médecine ça sauve beaucoup plus de vies que ça n'en gâche.
On se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo, d'ici là prenez soin de vous, prenez soin des autres et surtout portez-vous bien !